[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que le milliardaire
bill gates est un des boucs émissaires
de prédilection des conspirationnistes
mais depuis le début de la pandémie
bill gates bat des records a cédé pas un
chiffre qui dit tout le nom du
philanthrope américain a été associé aux
origines du coronavirus plus de 2
millions de fois selon les données
compilées par le new york times et la
firme ziegler labs qu'en pense le
principal intéressé
bill gates aurait comme projet
d'implanter une micropuce dans nos corps
au moyen d'un vaccin contre la copie 19
oui
l'idée serait d'intégrer une telle puce
sous cutanée pour pister ou encore
contrôler la population
l'affirmation est fausse et se base sur
une mauvaise interprétation des propos
de monsieur gates
il a suffi que le milliardaire évoque
l'utilisation de certificats numériques
dans un échange avec des internautes au
sujet du coronavirus pour que des
groupes anti vaccins récupère tout ça et
commencent à répandre l'idée selon
laquelle bill gates vise l'utilisation
d'un plan de micropuces pour combattre
le corps navires us en fait les tenants
de cette théorie on juxtapose et cette
affirmation l'un au fait que la
fondation bill et melinda gates co
finance un projet de recherche sur
d'éventuelles carnet de vaccinations
invisible de nanoparticules injectable
mais les certificats numériques et les
carnets de vaccination est visible sont
deux technologies distinctes aux
objectifs tout aussi différent selon ibm
un certificat numérique est un peu
l'équivalent numérique d'un permis de
conduire ou encore d'un passeport qui
dans le cas de la cabine 19 pour
indiquer si quelqu'un est déclaré
positif
il n'y a rien qui indique qu'il s'agit
d'une puce cutanées pour ce qui est du
carnet de vaccinations invisible l'idée
est d'injecter une encre invisible à
l'oeil nu mais détectable par un
téléphone intelligent qui servirait donc
à confirmer qu'une personne a bel et
bien été vaccinées l'idée est donc
d'offrir un moyen simple et abordable
pour faire diminuer le nombre de décès
évitables liées au manque de bases de
données centralisées sur les vaccins
pourquoi toutes ces théories sont
fausses et sans fond
demain je vous invite à lire sur notre
site web l'excellent article de notre
collègue nicolas de rosa et n'oubliez
pas aussi d'écouter notre émission
diffusée dès samedi dimanche sur i see
her dit salut
[Musique]